[Applause]
hi thank you for having me
how is it um your beautiful almost
one-year-old
she is she just turned nine months um so
it's
i mean she's just the cutest
little angel i've ever seen and i'm
obsessed with her as i'm sure
most parents say about their children um
and
it's the most fun role and experience
that i've ever had and i love absolutely
every single minute of it
it's been such a joy she's perfect
and um you are married to um chris pratt
who is just uh
i mean i've had luckily enough the
fortune and privilege of meeting him a
couple times he is always
the nicest human being he has the best
reputation
everybody loves him he's like the
coolest human on the planet
um when you met him uh
how long was it before you're like
you're the one
i mean we also we talk about that a lot
because i'm pretty sure we both
we both knew right away that that's
that you know this is where our
relationship was headed and we clicked
you know very quickly and um and so
he's the best and i'm so so grateful and
it's so beautiful to be able to watch
him
you know step into this new role of
being a girl dad and he's
the best husband and best dad and i feel
so grateful every single day for him
i am so happy for you it's so wonderful
to hear good people in the world
happy you know thank you happiness
is one of the greatest blessings
um and i am on a new mission
to really talk about the power of
forgiveness
what was the catalyst for you
to approach this subject
and put it at the forefront in this
extraordinary book
well thank you i mean i think that for
me forgiveness
the interest and forgiveness really came
when i
realized that i was really struggling
with forgiveness and my inability to
practice it
and i also didn't really know what it
meant to me and
it really just was so helpful to me to
be able to hear other people's
experiences and to hear
how people have struggled with it and
some still struggle with it and
how some people have been able to
practice it and also we don't really
talk about it yet we all
will experience it at some point in our
lives and
i feel really lucky that it's been able
to be helpful for other people as well
there is something really for everyone
in this book and i just want to thank
you for leading the charge
on helping people find an ability to do
such a courageous
important and liberating act and um i
know you also partnered with the baby
probiotic
um company and vivo is that how i
pronounce it
yeah in vivo it's crazy because you know
when i think a lot about just being a
new mom
and teaching her about so many things
and also being taught
about so many things and one of the
things that i i learned about was
newborn gut deficiency which actually
impacts over 90
of babies born in america and that's
just a
lack of good bacteria in babies guts
and it's crazy because we always hear
about like diaper rash
and colic in newborn babies and we think
that's normal but the reality is that
has a lot to do with
just an imbalanced gut and so just being
able to
have the ability to work with a company
like avivo and
give an infant probiotic is just really
incredible and i've had such a great
experience with it but it's like one of
those things that i want to share with
all new moms to be able to research
about newborn gut deficiency but then
also just be able to give it to their
babies
and you have an instagram series before
during and after baby will you tell us
about that
yeah it's been so incredible i recently
did one with my mom
for mother's day which was hilarious um
but i
i've had such a great time doing it and
i
it's all things before during after baby
so we
talk about everything from fertility to
pregnancy
to labor relationships sex
um newborn gut deficiency really just
all the different topics that we want to
know more about and we have guts uh
guests come on and talk about all these
subjects and we do it every thursday at
noon and
it's been such a fun experience for me
and i'm learning
so much as a new mom so it's also really
beneficial that way
well thank goodness for that and also i
was so excited to talk about this book
and i know it's new out in paperback um
the gift of forgiveness inspiring
stories from those who have overcome
the unforgivable yeah thank you thank
you catherine schwarzenegger pratt